on Tuesday morning we'll have our new
conservative leader and our next prime
minister but to get there they've got to
persuade their party there the man to
deliver they might not be counting
chickens yet but come next Monday at
5:00 p.m. the party will start counting
the votes the properly unassailable
frontrunner has had one message this
entire campaign and the party likes what
they hear we need to get our mojo back
as a as a party we need to get on and
get out of the EU on October the 31st
well done you've been I'm glad to say
you've been at least one thing has cut
through in the course of this election
campaign his rival fighting to the end
but as a remain of face in the
figurehead of vote leave it was probably
always a losing battle with this
particular crowd if we do this in a
gung-ho way if we go about it the wrong
way the Europeans will block any changes
to the deal Parliament will block No
Deal and we'll get to a general election
long before we get to October the 31st
so that's it the hustings are over the
race is nearly run Boris Johnson's
always been the front-runner the darling
of the grassroots the man that they're
most likely to entrust with the critical
task of delivering brexit both men say
they can do it but in reality it's going
to be much much harder to actually do as
they prepare for government the woman
leaving it with some pointed last words
for the men who would succeed her
getting things done rather than simply
getting them said requires some
qualities that have become unfashionable
of late one of them is a willingness to
compromise today an inability to combine
principles with pragmatism it has led to
what is in effect a form of absolutism
one which believes that if you simply
assert your view loud enough and long
enough you will get your way in the air
too little too late
the absolutism over brats it is already
here and cultivated on her watch
applause/cheers acylation for the one
who promises brexit by October the 31st
din or No Deal a winning formula here
for sure when it comes to actually
governing the rhetoric will surely clash
with the reality beth Rigby Stein News
London
[Applause]